alors moi j'ai eu la chance
arrivé en valais lors la rentrée
scolaire
14 et puis j'ai pu rillieux rentrée vous
faire j'ai commencé le deuxième cycle à
san luis et puis comme il a du gandalou
quand je suis arrivé je pourrais
sûrement français comprenaient rien je
peux rien dire en français puis quand
quelqu'un qui est enfin j'ai jamais
étudié le français auparavant et je
commençais deuxième cycle je peux vous
dire l'ambiance ou en général la vie
avec les autres gens qui parlent
français
c'était pas facile parce que comme j'ai
dit je parle pas français je contrôle je
comprenais pas ce qu'il me disait tout
et puis à l'école les gens ils venaient
les élèves et venait vers moi une parler
pour moi je restais comme ça je suis pas
quoi dire je comprends plus con con
parce qu'ils le disent
et puis c'était difficile pour moi du
coup je rentrais après l'école chez moi
je pleurais je voulais peut aller à
l'école
sinon ça sert à rien d'étudier parce que
j'apprends bien quoi et puis à chaque
fois je me dis non un moment il faut que
tu ailles ça va venir
il faut juste patienter et puis peu à
peu va j'ai commencé à prendre
et puis souvent souvent à l'école en
deuxième si j'essaie de parler quelques
mots anglais l'espoir pour parce que
sinon j'étais obligé de m'exprimer pour
dire ce que je veux dire puis puis je le
disais en anglais souvent mais ça l'est
parce savait pas trop bien alors fin de
deuxième cycle j'ai commencé la sas est
devenu mieux j'ai commencé à comprendre
ce que les autres disent j'arrivais à
répondre en quelques manches que ce
qu'il a ce qu'il a ce qu'ils m'ont dit
et puis ça j'étais assez content de
cette résultat parce que j'ai bien
progressé en deuxième cycle
c'était ma première année et puis là
c'est les vacances l'année les feelies
ses vacances d'été
bah je faisais rien c'était une chose
qu'il fallait pas faire parce que
j'étais tout le temps chez moi enfin pas
vraiment mais
je parlais je pratique je pratiquais pas
la langue française donc je parlais tout
le temps la raab avec mes amis où mes
parents la famille du coup j'ai oublié
une partie de ce que j'ai appris en 10e
6 du coup la rentrée en troisième cycle
c'était pas très top parce que j'ai de
nouveau recommencer
enfin non pas recommencer j'ai continué
à apprendre de nouveau mais un troisième
10 de sic j'ai mis le turbo pour les
jeux j'ai travaillé plus par exemple les
cours je suis pas n'importe quel cours
bah je suis en cours les autres epr en
cours avec le prof
et puis moi j'ai le livre où j'ai un
dossier ou une feuille bas je souligne l
mots que je prouve je comprenais pas
afin de jarry v avec toute la page qui
est souligné
je rentrais chez moi juste radio et où
c'était ça prenait du temps mais au
moins les résultats derrière en
troisième cycle même pareil qu'en
deuxième j'avais 6 ou 7 heures de cours
de français soutient voir à l'école
juste pour pour renforcer lé français
par semaine donc c'est sous cette heure
et puis moi je
vers noël donc 2ème année une année et
demie après l'arrivée bon j'ai réussi à
arrêter un cours de français je tiens et
puis faire à la place des maths avec les
autres comme les autres élèves
parce que là j'ai commencé vraiment à
faire des examens avec les autres pas
aller j'ai réussi à faire des amis donc
je sortais plus ou moins avec pour pour
améliorer le français ensuite pas en
troisième d'ici à trois ou six que j'ai
continué saleh
tout allait bien j'ai conseillé à
l'ambiance ça commence à devenir mu en
mieux
et puis à la fin de troisième cycle il y
avait un groupe à l'école qui on veut le
faire
diacre pour la remise de diplômes et
puis demande à un élève
ils ont cherché partout à l'école qu'ils
sont ouverts mois puis ils m'ont demandé
puis j'ai pas dit non alors j'ai on a
fait le répétition etc
et puis ma titulaire nous a dit à toute
la classe ce soir enfin avant la remise
ce soir j'appelle chaque personne pour
dire s'il passe ou pas enfin normalement
si je l'appelle c'est parce que vous
passez moi j'ai rien reçu ni d'appel
n'est rien puis je m'attendais même pas
que j'ai passé année parce que c'est
vrai j'ai fait les usa en affinant avec
les autres mais j'avais pas vraiment les
meilleures notes pour passer alors le
jour de la remise troisième derrière
derrière les rideaux et où on faisait
une partie de théâtre en sortait à la
classe qui sortent sur scène et c'est à
hyères atlas qui sort il ya tous les
noms qui sont annoncés à part moi je
suis là hier de rideau c'est normal je
n'attendais rien et puis director elle
dit le prix de la classe elle parle pour
malte avec et puis moi j'étais derrière
le rideau avec les avis théâtre et tout
c'est ouais c'était un peu j'étais
content mais en même temps j'étais
choqué parce que je m'attendais pas à ça
alors je suis sorti seul sur scène et
puis je reçois le diplôme que le prix de
la classe après on faisait on a fait le
l'ouest du théâtre
et puis c'est fini à toutes les classes
qui sont passés il ya de nouveaux
éléments de directeur et puis elle dit
le prix de 2 de l'école et par aussi
pointe avec est plus un mystère
j'arrivais pas exprimé si j'étais
content choqué tous ya tout qui se
mélanger ensemble mais j'ai passé f1 oui
j'ai passé l'année ont 3 m6 mais le
problème c'est que j'avais une place
d'apprentissage n'est une honte pour
aller au collège ou au lycée j'ai donc
là c'était un peu d'ici je savais même
pas que le pp ils comprennent plus près
professionnels existent alors ils m'ont
expliqué puis je suis un script c'était
le bon
ah le pp j'ai commencé comme n'importe
quel élève je n'avais pas de cours de
soutien
je peux aller c'est bien le français
pour réussir à être offertes ou quoi
j'ai de nouveau les cours d'allemand qu
auparavant j'avais pas au troisième
c'est que j'avais pas toutes les heures
et puis là j'ai tout c'était un peu
difficile appui bizarre parce que c'est
la première année où je faisais tout
comme les autres mais je me suis dit oui
je me suis mis des actes
et puis le premier semestre et a loupé
donc c'était ma troisième année d'études
ici en suisse même
3 on suit la première semestre
j'avais pas les nôtres pour aller à le
sujet parce que c'était mon rêve d'aller
à le cg et puis merci n'est ce pas
mathieu larnaudie moumen écoute papa
t'es vraiment deloitte et en échec
peut-être très loin de d aller en fait
c'était la mérite est grand
du coup je me suis mis à chercher une
place d'apprentissage en deuxième
semestre
j'ai trouvé une place d'apprentissage
sauf que on me au 2ème semestre
j'ai reçu mon bulletin et puis j'avais
bien les notes pour aller le sujet mais
notre saison ils ont bien grimper et
puis là j'étais content et puis va j'ai
bien sûr j'ai choisi le sujet sont sans
réfléchir direct jeudi au sujet des gt
direct aussi à leurs multiples entre
alep et aussi j'ai eu aussi le prix de
la classe s'étaient partagés entre man
et puis une autre fille une amère mois
elle aussi elle a fait de progrès et
puis c'était aussi j'étais aussi super
content c'est le prix de la classe et
c'est cool quand on a les vacances d'été
bat après le pp un jour je serai je
reçois un appel
je réponds oui bonjour je suis n'est pas
nouveau
et puis le dieu je suis journaliste du
nouvelliste est ce que vous seriez
d'accord que caen face à l'interview
avec vous sur le parcours que vous avez
fait
quand vous êtes union suisse etc
jusqu'aujourd'hui moi je dis oui
pas de souci alors on a fait l'interview
quelques jours après bahia sur
nouvelliste jaune alba la première page
une photo qui est en gros tout ce gîte
sur la première page et tout et puis le
monde ils ont tu le l'article et puis ça
m'arrivait souvent je ne suis pas allé à
l'école où j'allais en hongrois il ya
des gens qui m'arrêter je les connais
même pas on joue mais tout va bien et
c'est pas une connaissance de son avis
et puis moi je ne connais pas et puis je
continue à parler avec et puis oui et
puis quand j'ai pas l'âge inscrit à le
cg la première année elle va commencer
bientôt
les gens entrent à l'école la moité des
profs me connaissent ils ont vu le
journal et sita certains élèves aussi
bien vers moi c'est pas toi qui étais
aux journalistes j'ai dit oui c'est moi
elle était un peu tous choqués qu il ya
un accès sur le journal puis se trouve
chez pas dans la même classe que nous et
tout et puis ouais j'ai commencé je
conseille donc première au cg c'était
assez difficile aussi c'est pas le même
niveau qu'à louper c'est plus difficile
et où j'ai eu un peu de difficulté
surtout premier semestre
et puis paf c'est la même histoire j'ai
repris l'histoire de traduction à chaque
fois j'étais obligé parce qu'on avait
des livres est tout même une fois le ppj
ça m'arrivait j'avais un examen sion à
livre enfoncée et puis gelé j'ai lu deux
fois une fois en arabe
et puis une fois en français je les
traduis j'ai fini la lecture quelques
heures avant l'examen mais
j'ai une bonne note alors oui je
continue à le céser alors premier
semestre c'est qu'on a le pp les notes
il était en bas le deuxième semestre a
été en deçà bien grimpé aussi après j'ai
réussi le premier cgg ça j'ai choisi
d'aller en filière santé
et puis j'ai commencé c'est connu que
filière santé aux alleuds cgc plus du
seco filiation sociale mais c'est pas du
tout je dirais c'est pas vrai et
deuxième chose
un noël je me rappelle bien mon petit tu
erres deuxième de sujets il m'a fridor
puis il m'a dit écoute humaine voilà t
notés tous j'avais cinq ronds chauds
dessous des moyennes donc loin de là de
passer l'année
mathis est pas là si tu rates l'année
six tours double ça fait rien et tout
puis moi ne pas les centres est pas là
sortez pas la une sur vous avez raison
etc
alors j'ai continué mais pendant les
vacances de noël j'ai bien travaillé
plus il se dit c'est bon là je vais ce
sera sérieux au 2nd semestre je vais
tout faire être au point partout et puis
c'était le cas parce que j'ai réussi
l'année aussi 12e soit cité comme ça et
puis quand le profil est venu me donner
mon carnet la derniers jours m'a dit
franchement je suis choqué
courage c'est bien mais je n'attendais
pacte pas cette année prend pas méchant
mais je m'attendais pas parce que la fin
d'année j'avais dû branche une branche à
3,8 puis et l'autre à 3,9
donc j'avais bien travaillé et puis là
bas cette année du concept troisième de
cg je suis toujours en filière santé
et puis je vais continuer mes études
pour faire étudier la biologie et puis
faire un prof de biologie et puis je
vais terminer par vous dire allez-y tous
comme il l'a dit amélie avons choisi
c'est un mythe être qu'il vous plaît ne
nous dit pas que ouais je vais faire je
sais pas quel métier mais ça va durer
dix ans quinze ans ça il faut jamais le
dire il faut aimer votre métier et puis
tout va facilement
ça va passer vite moi je sais je vais
faire un prof de biologie c'est pas ça
va durer neuf disons mais je ne fais pas
de souci parce que c'est quelque chose
que j'aime deuxième chose que je veux
dire je suis passé entre vous et à se
trouve qu'il ya quelqu'un qui a passé
par là même même cas que moi qui aie qui
arrive et c'est qu'il ne parle pas le
français mais je pense alors je vais
dire que je vois je vois pas très bien
allez-y il faut pas il faut pas être
timide il faut que vous avez vous
intégré avec les autres les autres qu'il
vous fallait bien le français
allez-y vers le haut vers elle c'est
vraiment moi j'ai appris le trois-quarts
français que j'ai appris c'était avec
mes amis d'ailleurs je leur dis merci
beaucoup
parce que c'est grâce à eux que j'ai
j'ai appris le français et tous à
l'école ans on en apprend pas beaucoup
surtout vos pauvres
j'ai pas vous vous apprenez tous à
l'école mais pour moi la langue la 3 kg
après avec mes amis et tous donc allez-y
véreux et puis les gens qui est qui ont
un peu de difficulté à les airs les
autres il faut pas conseil timides ou
dans votre coin
c'est vraiment le sait c'est le moment
d'apprendre maintenant ou sinon après
c'est un peu difficile
et puis oui c'est j'ai tout j'ai tout
dit tu vois
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]